movilizados contra el velo en Irán
cientos de personas han salido a las
calles en Canadá para unirse a las
protestas en Irán que estallaron tras la
muerte de maxam Mini una mujer de 22
años que murió tras ser detenida por la
policía de la moral
señor ministro crudo No queremos que
hable con nuestro régimen no queremos
este régimen No queremos a la República
islámica queremos que Irán sea libre
en Grecia también se unen a la voz de
protesta
me estoy cortando el pelo porque muchas
de mis hermanas en Irán van a morir
Quizás mañana por culpa del jillaje y yo
no lo quiero y lo odio y no quiero
seguir a este régimen terrorista y
dictatorial
[Aplausos]
es un sentimiento del que se han hecho
eco la diáspora iraní en protestas por
toda Europa el sábado centros de
personas acudieron a esta manifestación
en Berlín donde algunas manifestantes
dicen que casi corrieron la misma suerte
Trágica que a Minnie junto a los
retratos de aminy los manifestantes en
Suecia mostraron fotos de otras
supuestas víctimas del régimen iraní
este
[Música]
régimen debe irse por todas las masacres
que hicieron en 40 años en Irán
intentamos llegar a los políticos de
Suecia y de otros países es lo único que
podemos hacer aquí
[Aplausos]
mientras las protestas se intensifican
en Irán en el vecino Irak decenas de
personas inundaron las calles de hervir
la muerte de aminia ha tocado la fibra
sensible de estas manifestantes muchas
de las cuales proceden de la parte iraní
del kurdistán la región natal de